un enfant sur 7 est victime de violence
dans le sport un bénévole sur de au
contact de nos enfants ne fait l'objet
d'aucun contrôle de ses antécédents
judiciaires et la plateforme de
signalement des violences sexistes et
sexuelles de votre ministère est méconnu
tous ces dysfonctionnements vous les
avez reconnu ils sont de votre
responsabilité pourtant votre priorité
depuis 10 jours et encore hier soir lors
des vœux du comité olympique a été
d'attaquer le travail du Parlement et de
notre commission et cela au mépris total
de la séparation des pouvoirs ce rapport
a pourtant été largement salué par les
pour lesqu vous n'avez eu aucun mot ce
rapport vous dérange car il vient
bousculer votre caste de privilégié il
démontre que la France n'a pas
totalement tourné le dos à une logique
aristocratique d'accaparement du pouvoir
digne des descriptions de Balzac et
écrivait en parlant du faubourg
Saint-Germain quartier que vous
connaissiez bien le travail se couche
lorsque l'aristocratie songe àîné ce
système vous permet de maintenir
quelques familles au pouvoir des clans
dirons-nous digne d'une période
largement dépassée cet entre soi
consanguin vous a fait passer sans
aucune réserve et sans la moindre
procédure de recrutement d'une société
privée à une grande fédération sportive
avec à la clé un salaire jugé anormal
par l'Inspection Générale placée sous
votre propre autorité dire aujourd'hui
que l'on perd de l'argent en étant
ministre dire que 500000 € de salaire en
étant dirigeante et mérité doit hulcérer
les agriculteurs qui bloquent nos routes
en ce moment pour espérer toucher ne
serait-ce qu'un SMIC et qui se heurte à
la sururdité du gouvernement dans votre
monde les grandes familles se croisent
se regroupent et s'associent vous y
croisez notamment le chemin de Marc ladr
de la Charrière dont on connaît depuis
l'affaire Fillon les talents en
recrutement et en gestion de carrière
tout cela incarne bien la transformation
du président de la République entre sa
première élection et la fin de son
second sacre il nous avait promis le
Nouveau Monde il nous l'IG finalement
l'Ancien Régime madame la ministre ma
question est simple plus que dans votre
monde il est normal de toucher 500000 €
pour les heures de travail en fourner
comme vous le dites quelle considération
méritent les agriculteurs les
professeurs et les bénévoles sur les
terrains
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Amélie udea Castera ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des
sports bon madame la députée madame la
députée Sabrina sbail donc vous
recommencez à m'attaquer à m'attaquer
personnellement alors je vais d'abord
vous remercier pour votre question qui
est en effet l'occasion pour moi de
saluer à la fois la présidente bami pour
son effort constant d'objectivation des
travaux de la commission d'enquête et de
remercier de saluer chacun des
parlementaires qui ont contribué à la
bonne marche de ces travaux avec un
objectif faire progresser le sport c'est
le mien aussi et je vous en
remercie simplement voilà ce travail
parlementaire de qualité vous l'avez
dévoyé vous l'avez dévoyé dans votre
rapport dans l'atterrissage dans votre
rapport o vous en êtes servi pour
diviser pour attaquer pour stigmatiser
sur les plateaux télé dans les réseaux
sociaux ou par des formules à
l'emporte-pièces et ça vous l'avez fait
par opportunisme pour surfer sur la
vague médiatique des crises des
fédérations que nous avons géré que nous
avons solutionné arrêtez de donner des
leçons madame sbahi où étiez-vous où
étiez-vous depuis 2020 quand le
gouvernement a pris à brasle corp comme
aucun avant lui le sujet de la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes dans le sport où étiez-vous
madame la députée en novembre dernier
lorsqu'on a discuté ici même les crédit
pour le sport pour 2024 avec des moyens
inédits que nous avons réussi à
décrocher pour la lutte contre les
violences vous étiez absente madame la
députée vous étiez absente de ces débats
et moi j'ai poussé pour les signalements
la progression du contrôle de NS
habilités j'ai été constamment comme je
continuerai à l'être au côté des
victimes de violence à caractère sexiste
ou sexuel madame la députée je suis
fierre du travail que nous avons
entrepris et lucide sur ce qui reste à
accomplir pour améliorer notre modèle
sportif ce combat pour l'éthique
l'intégrité dans le sport il mérite
mieux que de veines attaques
politicienne ce combat pour le sport
nous devons le mener et le mener tous
ensemble merci beaucoup madame la
ministre